[Music]
let's go out to Dear Marie in
Pennsylvania what's up
Marie hi Dr John thank you so much for
taking my call today of course thanks
for calling what's up well um I have
less of a question and more just asking
for help I got you let's do it um just
needing some help dealing with some
feelings I'm having recent ly um my
daughter just got married about a month
ago and um we absolutely love our
son-in-law and we're so happy for them
we had a great wedding a great
celebration um but I'm as soon as the
celebration ended I began feeling this
immense sense of sadness and
grief um almost over like a loss and
I've just been having a hard time coming
to terms with that and trying to
understand why I'm feeling the way I'm
feeling man I'm smiling right
now and here's why because most of the
parents I talk to these days have no
relationship with their
kid okay and you love
yours I do more than anything what made
your relationship with with your
daughter
special well I can give you a little bit
of background because um although all
parents think their child is special I
really mine is special here we go Mar
I'm just kiding here we go go ahead well
just to give you some background um my
daughter was born with um a set of very
rare and complicated heart
defects and 26 years ago when she was
born uh we were told at that time you
know there's things that can be done um
to help her her but there's very good
likelihood that she won't survive to her
first
birthday so we did all the things that
they told us to do multiple heart
surgeries procedures therapies lots of
hospital stays she made it to the first
birthday and she made it to the second
and the third and so
on so um over the course of her life
lots of other things have happened but
overall she's been able to not just
survive but really Thrive and better
than we had ever been told she would be
capable of and we're so grateful by the
grace of God that that she has had the
life that she has had so you know she
grew up she went to college she's
graduated with honors and she's great
career in healthc care right now she's
back in grad school working to advance
her career and she really has had you
know what we had always wanted for her a
a normal life despite her health
condition she's had some recent
challenges on top of her heart disease
she about three years ago is diagnosed
with a pituitary
adenoma so she's getting treated for
that as a result of her heart condition
she has liver uh therosis we're dealing
with that but as I said she's just had
this you know god-given life that we're
so blessed and I should be really happy
that you know she has gone on to make
all these achievements and have this
perfect life and find the man of her
dreams and the week after her wedding I
was cleaning her room and rearranging
the furniture because I was so sad okay
hold on you're not sad that she's
married that's not what you're grieving
no you lost your
job some gross hairy legged boy took
your
job and in doing so he took your
identity because you haven't taken a
full breath in 26 years have
you I tried to but you haven't taken a
full breath in 26 years and now you just
passed her over to this boy that says
I'm
in right I cannot think of a harder
thing for a parent to do other than to
bury a child than what you've done
so your grief and your sadness that now
you're in search of a new identity a new
role like a new a new
thing because you've been on call for 26
years
right right I feel that I do so give
yourself a minute okay give yourself a
minute and your purpose has changed and
your role has changed you're still mom
you'll always be mom
and if anything tragic happens and let's
be honest she's got a lot of challenges
ahead of her right yes of course so
um I want to say it this way and tell me
if I if I'm misguided or wrong okay
okay can we can I just can I just speak
as openly and direct as possible is that
okay absolutely okay you've been through
enough that you can just you can just
hear it straight right oh yes absolutely
okay therosis Deema heart
issues
um like there's a lot of mileage on her
sweet body right yeah a lot of challenge
in repair and surgery her body's already
tired and she's 26 years old right right
for
25.9% of those years you've dealt with
that fragility by hanging on real
tight and you'll beat every single
marker that they gave
you and also you know time is is fragile
and short
right yes I do okay you know that in
your soul and you took your hands off
the wheel you had
to because she said mom I want him to
drive as she should right and so there's
that
chaotic Reckless moment not Reckless
that's the wrong word there's this
chaotic terrifying scary
moment where you send your kids out to
the Wild and in this case you know what
the Wild's going to
ultimately how it's going to ultimately
end
yeah and so instead of trying to make
yourself feel better by holding your
hands so tightly around here that she
couldn't
move you did one of the noblest most
amazing things a mom could do in this
situation which is let your
daughter make adult
choices and go live a wild Reckless
Love and work a w work a wild
job
and I got to rearrange the furniture cuz
I'm just going to weep for a
while Fair
yeah yeah I you know and and I've always
thought you know that I wasn't holding
on too tight because you know that was
something I didn't want for her her
whole life I didn't want her to be you
know this weird sick kid all the time um
so I always sort of prided myself and
being the mom that you know let her go
and do things that were were scary and
dangerous
um given her condition but I wanted her
to live life you know I always said if
her life was going to be short it was
going to be great God hold on hold on
hold on do you realize how amazing you
are I'm serious listen oh my
gosh what an amazing mom you are thank
you and that sounds so awesome on
Instagram and that sucks when you're
living it out every day right it's hard
it's so
hard but here's what you're doing in
real time and most parents in our
current culture cannot do this I hope
you hear me getting all fired up man
it's like making it's bringing me so
much joy okay most parents in our
current
world I'll just it's a current world in
our current culture use their kids to
prop up their own egos
and you are not doing
that you are saying no I am G to do what
I can to keep you safe and keep you
alive so that you can run wild and free
and your run is not going to be as long
as the kids you went to college with we
all know
that but I don't want to have gently
walked to the Finish Line with you
holding your hand the whole way and
making sure you didn't stub your toe and
we get to the Finish Line that's not
what I'm
doing I want you to
run right and and I've I do feel that
way and I always have felt that way and
and then and then she got married and
now I'm like
okay now what do I do yes so here's
here's I I want you to be really
specific you're not you're not grieving
her wedding I don't believe that I think
you're really in your soul so happy and
I don't know who this boy
is but but what an amazing
man what amazing man he really is um so
I don't think you're grieving the
wedding I think you're grieving Your
Role has changed
dramatically and that's okay and so I
want you to feel permission to spend
time being incredibly
sad that's
okay I don't want you to use your
daughter as a Xanax to make you feel
better though you're the you're the mom
you're the adult so it's going to be up
to you to go hang out with your friends
go exercise go on a trip go do whatever
you need to do to stay whole and well
right hopefully it's constructive things
not destructive things but it's your job
to be sad that I mean that's feel fully
full permission to do that okay okay
you're not crazy to say something wrong
with you okay okay and then at some
point the ultimate healing part of this
is as David Kessler says you're going to
go make meaning of it what is that what
does that mean in real life that sounds
all lofty I'm gonna go make meaning
here's what it here's what that actually
means with with skin and Knuckles on the
ground here's what this
means it
means why
you why did the cosmos the universe or
God why did they give you this
beautiful young
girl to raise and protect and send out
to the wild why are
you and what are you going to do with
that are you going to be a mom that runs
a Facebook page for parents who find out
their kids have some really difficult
medical needs are you going to be the
mom that brings um kids kids with
special needs from college over to your
house over the holidays and serve
Thanksgiving dinner long after your
daughter has
passed are you going to be like what how
are how is the world going to be
different because of what you've learned
and what you've experienced that's
making meaning it doesn't have to be a
grand
gesture but it can be right right but
that's not for today it's not for today
most people skip the being sad part and
with they do is they create a kinetic
hurricane of of of
activity and they help a bunch of people
and they are so hollow inside you can
you you know they they blow over with
the slightest
wind so unfortunately for you and your
husband you have to feel
this
right I don't think my husband's feeling
it the way I am though I promise he is I
promise he is
he he doesn't say uh he he thought I was
kind of overreacting over the last
couple weeks as I had been sobbing over
her Barbie dolls in her bedroom oh you
tell him to park it you're
overreacting
whatever his moment will come his moment
will come but here's the deal everybody
reacts to this stuff differently
everybody Grieves differently as David
keler says grief is like a fingerprint
everybody does it
differently but your role has changed
your purpose has changed no I don't know
your purpose is I'm going to continue to
love my baby girl just what that looks
like is going to be different now
because love used to look like staying
up all night making sure that heart
monitor was still beating love used to
look like walking far enough behind her
that she felt autonomous but close
enough you could catch her if she fell
and for a long time love look
like singing her way to college but then
keeping up with her checking on her
grades making sure she she was okay and
then love looked like
planning a
wedding and now Love's going to look
different it's going to look
different and as my favorite poet
Stephen Connell
says love looks like come what come I'll
be right
here and you get to decide what that
looks like and maybe a fun conversation
after your daughter gets home from her
honeymoon or kind of the Smoke Clears a
little bit you take her out and say
honey I have been trying to keep you
alive for so long how can I love you in
this new
season because you're a grown woman now
you're all married up ew
ew but you get to be sad
Mom I wish the world had more mares in
it it's such an honor that I got to talk
to you
today